[Music]
mankind and the elements
for some
it's an uncomfortable bond it's not
really a good idea to have divers in the
water with a thunderstorm for others
when weather strikes
inspiration begins if they have a
catastrophe
we can be there to help them
these are the people who challenge
nature
seek out its limits
reveal its secrets
and embrace its awesome power
in this episode we'll meet an elite team
of diver scientists using an underwater
laboratory as a home base for scientific
research our scientists can spend days
and weeks underwater a man growing
millions of trees to be planted across
the devastated forests of the american
west
i'll always work with plants there's no
way fans are butts and in boulder
colorado an extraordinarily gifted rock
balancer
my approach was to experiment what
happens if i add one more rock these
pioneers are the great outdoors ahead
and that's amazing
[Music]
if you find yourself in the creeks of
boulder colorado you may come across
this man yoda is like one of the grand
masters
and one of his major things was try not
only do there is no try michael grab is
a rock balancing extraordinaire and a
prominent member of a growing global
community that's kind of a philosophical
approach to all of this is you just do
it and you don't think about it he's
determined to master this natural art
form and his approach and discipline
boggles the mind if you think too much
about it then it collapses and you break
fingers
my name is michael grab and i'm a stone
balance artist i just balance rocks
every day i just started doing it
randomly one day in boulder creek
about eight years ago and it just kind
of turned into a therapeutic kind of
activity practice ritual so i just kept
doing it
boulder is a really beautiful place to
wake up in the morning there's just a
special feeling about being here
especially when i'm going to the creek
every day because it's just kind of this
constant renewal of energy coming
through the city it's kind of an ideal
place for rock balancing
the whole learning process with
balancing rocks is very organic in my
experience like i just started making
tall towers biggest rock to smallest
rock
and you do that enough every day for
years
and eventually you start noticing
nuances and you start taking it a bit
further and a bit further it's just kind
of like a universal human activity and
that's something i find to be really
fascinating about all of it like i
thought i was the only person doing it
for a long time then i came to learn
that all these people in like pretty
much every continent except antarctica
balance rocks
one of my big inspirations was a guy i
saw online named bill dan he's kind of
the pioneer of the whole counterbalance
style a counterbalance is just where one
rock holds another rock in place so if
that rock is removed then the other rock
falls i usually start by looking for a
nice top rock like a big rock i'm gonna
display on top i kind of look for the
rarest rock possible something with an
interesting feature like color or shape
sometimes i'll just go where the
interesting rocks are then i might spend
an hour to just figuring out where in
that spot i want to build that kind of
drives a lot of the creative process
most people when they watch me they just
see me completely frozen but what i'm
doing is every
split second i'm juggling anywhere from
three to nine different contact points
or vertices of balance just like trying
to isolate certain connections it's like
a three-dimensional gravity rubik's cube
that's the way i visualize it
the zero point is a term i began calling
the moment when i know that it's
balanced and i can let go it's kind of
this infinite feeling where there's no
separation between me and these objects
there's a few elements that go into like
the quintessential stone balancer
there's
rock selection
location selection and
photographic skill a lot of balancers
are strong in one aspect and weak in
another but my goal is to be exceptional
in all three i'm kind of a perfectionist
even though the art form itself says no
he can't be a perfectionist
one of the special things about rock
balancing is you surprise yourself often
if you're willing to just experiment
what happens if i add one more rock and
that's kind of the universal dilemma for
any rock balancer either it collapses or
it stays balanced there's been so many
times where
i just wanted to quit like there was a
storm coming in it was windy it started
raining or it's snowing and my fingers
are freezing but i just keep going
because i know it's possible i
visualized it i felt it but it just
takes those micro adjustments and
95 of the time it usually works out if i
stick with it long enough and sticking
with it long enough can be a few days
it's like a yoga almost it's like a pure
deep meditation and maybe that sounds a
little bit hokey pokey but it's a real
feeling
[Music]
the staggering views in space can play
tricks on the eyes and the mind
astronaut leland malvin explains
[Music]
as we run around the planet at 17 500
miles per hour you saw this
green glow when you're in the southern
hemisphere and in the northern
hemisphere you see these purple and
yellow and blue lights just popping from
the particles hitting the atmosphere
every orbit the sun rises and sets every
45 minutes so as you go around the
planet you see this
setting and then another 45 minutes
later the rising of the sun
on my first mission i was told that
cosmic rays would come through the
vehicle and hit your optical nerve it
would make you think you're seeing
flashes of light even though that's not
really happening the flashes were like a
sunburst of different colors
you would see this
streaks of color popping in your eyes
and in your head
sleeping in space is pretty incredible
because you're floating inside your
sleeping bag but then you had this whole
den of pumps and
motors and things whizzing around you
and so it's almost like a you're in a
factory in a mechanical kind of sounding
automation going on
my dreams were so vivid from all the
stimulus from the day i saw
blues greens whites whether they came
from
the ocean whether it came from the sun
whether it came from flashes in my head
from these high-energy particles
the colors were intertwined into my
dream state and i saw
sometimes alien forms the green aurora
australias is moving and
dancing so you know you think of a
little green man on mars there was one
point
in the mission where i started dreaming
about a
inside out cheeseburger with the most
grease and
just chomping into this hamburger
something that we cannot have in space
and also a big big slice of pizzas
i think because i've had these
experiences and i've seen these
incredible things in the universe
all of that's now incorporated into my
dreams now so i constantly dream about
lights flashing and colors and
velvet
pitch black night sky and these little
white lights coming through
my name is leland melvin
i'm an astronaut and a great big
storyteller
at any given moment there's more than a
million asteroids hurling through our
solar system
most will never come close to our planet
but nasa doesn't have the bandwidth to
keep track of them all
that's where a small community of
ordinary citizens steps in
backyard astronomers
gary hug is one of them i really like to
discover things that haven't been
discovered yet
a retired machinist who turned his love
of astronomy into a full-time affair
if you discover an asteroid that's one
you found nobody else in the world knew
about that asteroid before you saw it
he's discovered more than 300 flaming
balls of ice and rock all by peering
into a telescope he designed and built
himself
what i've been doing here lately and and
for about 15 16 years now
i've been working with near-earth
objects
my observations contribute to
making sure that we don't have something
coming up that's going to fall on our
head
kind of first got into it probably 10 12
years old i was begging begging begging
to get a telescope but and you know we
were in a very rich family so it took a
while to get it and one christmas i got
telescope then i started using it and i
got aperture fever
you want bigger telescopes all the time
so i started learning how to build them
i learned how to how to work in a
machine shop
i can build things that i wanted to
build
and a lot of that was astronomy parts
i kind of modified my life to fit this
study this kind of lifelong study
sandlot is
a very tiny little observatory it's only
10 foot by 10 foot wide
the telescope i built
over a period of about a year and a half
and it may not look very polished
it works really well
i'm good with that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i don't have a degree in astronomy
i have a passion for astronomy
and i've done it for many many years and
i've i've contributed i think to the
scientific body of astronomy that's
that's really kind of a
yeah from that standpoint i am an
astronomer
[Music]
is
a
[Music]
you know
[Music]
[Music]
considered
[Music]
grande
[Music]
or
[Music]
well when you buy from local guys it
comes back to you and you know you're
getting a local fish it's sustainable
that's an honest thing
sometimes we forget that we are part of
the ecosystem we are animals too and we
are very ignorant
very ignorant
[Music]
[Music]
i've always been inspired or fascinated
by weather what does a cloud sound like
you know even as a child i can remember
sitting out on the grass and looking up
at the clouds as they go past
what kind of sound would those clouds
output using a piano if they if they
roll across the keys
my name is david bowen i'm a studio
artist and educator
i make kinetic and robotic sculpture and
often these robotic devices respond to
some sort of natural input
cloud piano is a robotic installation
that plays the piano based on the
movement and density of the clouds as i
move across the sky
as you can see it's a device that mounts
to the keyboard of a piano and there's
another component a camera that's
mounted outside the building here and as
clouds go past the camera that the video
is sent in real time to a computer that
then scales the data what i've done is
taken the video feed from the camera and
chopped it into 88 individual pieces as
if they are the 88 keys on the the
keyboard so as the clouds go past a
particular key that key is pressed and
so it's basically a simple algorithm i
suppose that says if you see more white
than blue in this little section of the
video then press that key
i guess you could think of it then as
maybe a collaboration where i set up
this certain situation and i'm making
these choices but
after that it's kind of up to the
weather
[Music]
these
odd
sounds that the piano is making continue
to build or dissipate or move and change
shape
machines or computers are thought to be
very orderly and very precise and
likewise nature is thought to be very
chaotic what keeps me interested is i
think there's a lot of
systematic ways to look at these things
that we associate with chaos
[Music]
every year the world's most elite
mountain bikers gather in france for a
race unlike any other
it's
the longest uh
dhoni race in the world
mcgava lance is 18 miles long to be
exact and it's an adrenaline-filled ride
through all four seasons starting in an
unlikely spot for a bike race
eleven thousand feet up on the
snow-capped summit of peak blanc
in the french alps
this is remy absalon he won the
gavalanche
i started mountain bike when i was young
enduro and mountain bike is
really cool because we can explore all
around the world
mecca avalanche alperus takes place in
the french harps in halperduez so not so
far of italy and switzerland
it's
really high in harps so you have a
very good
view 360 degrees
around you
it's really crazy i don't know why
i do that
we ride all kinds of terrain first the
glacier and after the rocky section the
forest
[Music]
is very physical with
some happiness so when you cross the
line and you are first
you're you're really happy and
you want to to try again
[Music]
about a third of the united states is
covered in forests
in places like colorado
those forests are in danger
there's fire our wildfires are getting
more frequent and larger
a devastating beetle infestation those
trees are all dead they don't have any
branches anymore they're just standing
sticks
and global warming
there is hope
and it's found in an unlikely place
when i tell people that i work at a
forest in nebraska they they usually
laugh and they're like nebraska has a
forest
richard gilbert is a man on a quest
he's a biological scientist who works
here
at the charles bessey nursery in halsey
nebraska
it's the oldest federal tree nursery in
the u.s
the nursery's main mission is to help
preserve and repopulate national forests
in the rocky mountain region
without bessie they're not going to be
able to have the supply of trees that
they need for reforestation
if they have a catastrophe
we can be there to help them
[Music]
you know i think most of the perception
for nebraska is that it's large and it's
flat very boring not pretty at all lots
of corn and soybeans
but there's lots of beauty here there
really is nebraska had been treeless
1800s it was has been treeless for quite
some time
charles e bessie was a botany professor
at the university of nebraska absolutely
loved nebraska loved the sand hills he
loved trees
his mission was to
get a forest planted somewhere
in nebraska
they got seedlings out of the black
hills they got seedlings out of
minnesota
and they brought them here and planted
them onto the forest
twenty thousand acres were hand planted
here
it was chosen for the plentiful water
the sand in the ease of producing the
seedlings and extracting them out of the
soil getting them bundled up and planted
back out onto the forest very quickly
what i love most about my job is really
the change in season and the change in
work that i do i get to work in the seed
bank i get to work in the container part
of this i get to work in the field
and i get to actually get my hands dirty
i don't just sit in an office and and
push paper
richard's amazing he really
cares
and he's always trying to make it better
we turn the greenhouses on you got
little seedlings germinating it to me
it's spring so my spring starts really
early
and it's extremely rewarding
he's very proud of his work he's very
proud of his trees
i love growing plants and helping them
grow i don't ever want to lose that that
contact with the plants
[Music]
the san juan national forest i think is
about 1.6 million acres
one of our biggest challenges that's
happening is we have a large epidemic of
spruce beetle happening on the san juan
national forest
we believe that the beetle epidemics
were controlled by cold winters climate
change is happening and we know up here
that we have not had cold winters cold
winters is what controls beetle
epidemics but the beetles use the sap
from the tree to help fill up and
protect their eggs it's sawdust and egg
and sap all mixed together
[Music]
where we're seeing the spruce beetle
attacking the trees when those trees are
all dead they don't have any branches
anymore they're just standing sticks
they're starting to fall over
the spruce beetle epidemic that we're
seeing is unprecedented
we collect
seed from the trees
early before with the beetles hit to
maintain a seed bank bessie nursery is a
very important part of our organization
they are the ones who store all of our
seed and they grow all the seedlings for
us
when they need them we grow them and we
get them produced in less than a year
all of the trees are produced in the
greenhouses and then they are brought in
here on tables this y is okay because
it's above halfway and we have a central
leader
we can pack 110 to 120 000 trees per
belt per day
we are packing container trees for the
san juan national forest
they don't get their moisture in the
spring a lot of times they get their
summer monsoon seasons that's when they
want their seedlings delivered richard
remembers all of this information and
wants the feedback and wants to know how
they did at our best we might get 70 80
survival
without bessie they're not going to be
able to have the supply of trees that
they need for reforestation
rich gilbert is very proactive
then he's adapting and doing as much as
he can to to prepare the nursery into
the future
starting from a seed to a finished
product
and it's a wonderful experience to be
able to be part of that
these trees are going to outlast me and
they're going gonna outlast rich
it's not often you can have that kind of
legacy on a landscape
plants are just amazing and there are so
many of them out there and i will never
know how to grow every single one if
it's a very very interesting plant i'll
try to produce it and grow it at the
house and if you guys drive by my house
over there you'll understand you'll see
all the different plants that i have
over there
across the planet
coral reefs are dying at an alarming
rate
scientists estimate that 30 percent of
the ocean's reefs have disappeared due
to human activity
and rising ocean temperatures coral is
kind of like the trees of a forest
they're just the backbone of a whole
tropical ecosystem and if they disappear
we're in a lot of trouble
ken nedermeier is coral's last best hope
he developed the coral tree nursery
a simple framework of pvc pipe tethered
to the ocean floor
in this nursery he is able to grow brand
new fragments of elkhorn and staghorn
coral and replant them on struggling
reefs in the florida keys
he's planting 25 000 new corals a year
and his methods are inspiring
conservationists across the tropics
[Music]
i've been growing up diving spent a lot
of time in the water one two three
and i basically watched the coral reefs
dying as the reefs died the fish didn't
come back and i realized i'm tired of
watching it die i need to do something
about it
and so i developed this whole idea of
growing corals in an offshore nursery
and replanting them on the reef
so you're kind of like a farmer
i'm a farmer
yeah we grow corals just like a farm
there's a good time of the year to plant
and there's a harvest time and we have
five offshore nurseries in the keys
each tree can hold a hundred corals
we start with little fragments that we
collect and after six to nine months
maybe a year that fragment has turned
into a colony that might have 100
centimeters of growth on it we cut that
off and then we plant it out on the reef
so we just harvested some corals and
we're going to take them out to pickles
reef right now and plant them we've got
a couple thousand of them out there that
we've already planted and we're gonna
add some more
it is a bit of gardening when you put
the corals back out on the reef you're
saying i think that would look nice over
there and that would look nice over
there and some of it's based on
what used to be there and what should be
there and that's how we do our planting
we planted 20 000 already this year
we'll plant 25 000 next year those
corals will probably spawn next year
part of the long range goal is get the
corals reproducing on their own
i'm excited every time i get in the
water whether i'm going to work in the
nursery or whether i'm planting corals
or just looking for new areas to plant a
lot of people said oh you can never do
that i can't do it on a big enough scale
and i think i've proven that it can be
done and if we can train enough people
and teach enough people in other places
i think we can really see a significant
turnaround another day another coral
[Music]
the world's oceans are under siege
marine life is dying at alarming rates
due to accelerating pollution
overfishing and climate change people
keep saying we're at a tipping point
some people say we're beyond a tipping
point but six miles off the shores of
key largo
and 60 feet deep sits aquarius
the world's only underwater research
laboratory
there is no other place where people
live underwater and work on the water
for extended periods of time
the diver scientists who work here are
called aquanauts and they come from all
over the world to spend weeks at florida
international university's underwater
lab
conducting cutting edge research on
oceanic health
this elite group faces danger in the
elements for the sake of the planet in a
race against time
[Music]
the first time i saw an ocean i was
amazed by the vast expanse it really
made me feel insignificant
as i started to spend more and more time
around the ocean i start to see
that we do affect what's happening under
water
we're seeing ocean acidification we're
seeing
coral reef decline and we see a lot of
degradation
[Music]
what i don't think people realize is the
impact that oceans have on people in the
middle of the country everything
associated with the ocean controls
climate controls local weatherized
patterns
the world's reefs have been valued at
375 billion dollars annually that's for
fisheries tourism protection
of the coastline from storms the
research at aquarius is being conducted
at a critical time
aquarius aquarius reef based
that's a roger we got the main lock on
aquarius is the last undersea research
laboratory dedicated to science and
education in the world today
there is no other underwater habitat
doing what we do how we do it it allows
researchers to live at their study site
they can do incredibly long working
dives dives which couldn't be done from
the surface
when you're diving from the surface the
deeper you go the less time you have
when you
live underwater the habitat actually
becomes your surface when you dive
from the habitat which is about 50 feet
and you dive to 90 feet you're not
really diving to 90 feet you're really
diving to 40 feet from the surface so
now what you've done is you've extended
that time period that you can actually
spend that 90 feet that's where it
really separates from the traditional
research or work that's done from
vessels on the surface of the water that
makes a big difference marine ecologists
use it as a base of operation others
want to use it for extreme environment
mission operations we do
a number of projects with nasa and they
say that aquarius is very similar to
what astronauts experience in space
in the 50s 60s and 70s we had 60 or 70
research labs underwater and now we're
down to one in 2011 there was a shift
within congress so the national oceanic
and atmospheric administration started
to pull back in funding every one of the
science community said you know what
we've got to do what we can to save this
fiu left at the opportunity
it makes it official the fiu age of
aquarius
has begun
we had gone from getting ready to shut
it down and here we are almost four
years later and we're still going
[Music]
you can control a lot of things but you
can't control the weather we make a
choice to take on the inherent risks
that are associated with being exposed
to the elements
the constant real-time changes that
occur with weather the possibility of
getting stranded out at sea
the surface crew is forced to postpone
operations right now it's not really a
good idea to have divers in the water
especially with a thunderstorm that has
lightning strikes
but the aquinas below continued their
work
uninterrupted
everybody who works in an offshore
environment fully understands that that
mission may be postponed a week
a month may be cancelled at any
[Music]
time everybody when they're five years
old wants to be an astronaut or a marine
biologist i never grew out of it living
and doing science underwater is the
coolest thing i could possibly imagine
what does it take to become an aquanaut
we look at people who have considerable
experience underwater diving has to be
second nature and it's not uncommon for
people not to finish aquanaut training
they start to understand that maybe
psychologically
i'm not prepared to be in a confined
environment with five other people for
10 days that's the typical length of
missions but we have done longer ones
we've done 16 day we've done 18 day and
the longest one to date have been 31
days long we've saturated 392
scientists now both you guys got your
mask things bc deathgate freshgate's
computer check i can honestly tell you
from the bottom of my heart that i enjoy
waking up in the morning and then coming
to work
yeah i enjoy my job a lot it's not an
easy job keeping queers going constantly
fighting
weather constantly fighting corrosion
but
every day we wake up and say all right
we've got to do something today because
what's happening with the oceans isn't
stopping
[Music]
this team of hawaiian sailors is on what
might sound like an impossible mission
to sail around the world using only the
sun and the stars as their guide
their boat is a replica of a historic
polynesian voyaging canoe
she's called the hokulea
there's no motor no nails no metal to
hold her together just ropes
the goal for captain bruce blakenfeld
and his crew
to honor their ancestors who use this
form of navigation
and prove it is possible to sail the
open seas
without any modern technology
[Music]
voyaging canoes the mode of
transportation for navigating the vast
area
of polynesia you know it's like over
three million square miles
and that was the way our ancestors
traveled
this is our culture and we're
celebrating that
so we're on hokulea
she is a replica of a
polynesian voyaging canoe
the hokulea was built with the express
purpose of proving that navigation by
the ancient way was very viable these
canoes could be guided over 2 000 miles
and long distances
[Music]
there's about five miles of rope on this
canoe so that's definitely traditional
there's no metal there's no screws
there's no nails there's no braces that
hold the canoe together
there's no navigation equipment that we
use to go across the ocean
when we're navigating the open ocean our
biggest clue that tells us where we are
and where we're going is the sun the sun
as we know rises in the east and sets in
the west so if we just know where one
point of is then we know where
everything else is
the stars do us the same thing it's like
the compass in the sky we memorize close
to 200 stars and know where they rise
and where they set and how they move
across the skies
the sun and the stars and everything
work in conjunction with the swells
so in the absence of the sun
then you maintain the the orientation of
the crew to those small patterns that's
a very difficult thing
[Music]
we started in hawaii in end of may 2014
we embarked on this worldwide voyage
which first ended up going towards
tahiti through our ancestral routes and
now we're here in martha's vineyard
[Music]
we see this overwhelming support from
peoples all around the world
hokulea is a symbol of of hope and of
pride
[Music]
a big part of this voyage right malama
honua is to train a whole cadre
of young navigators and captains
wait don't leave the back sail let's get
the 23 out
a big four sail
[Music]
wong
is one of the apprentice navigators
he understands that you know it's going
to take
long hours and lack of sleep
he understands how to use all the tools
that nature provides
kaleo and these others they're just like
a pinch of salt as far as the people who
know how to do this type of navigation
[Music]
when i'm on hokulea you know
and we're sailing in the open ocean i
feel like definitely a deep sense of
pride of what our ancestors were able to
do and what we can still do today when
we're in the middle of the ocean we're
seeing the same swells that they would
have saw the same stars that they would
have been looking at and using the same
birds the same everything in the ocean
but when we're on the canoe definitely
connected more to our culture to our
people to our ancestors
[Music]
you